you've heard of the famous
astrophysicist Ice Cube before haven't
you did you know each other
no no not that guy today we're diving
deep under the ice in Antarctica to
reveal the real NWA neutrinos with
anisotropy come along way down under
scientists recently looked for a new
space-time structure using the largest
chunk of ice ever made
antarctic ice sheet down at the South
Pole Antarctica and this is what they
found using the Ice Cube neutrino
Observatory which has been operating for
almost 10 years at the South Pole
scientists probed the nature of space
and time itself using ghost particles
the neutrinos and scientists recently
published a result
one of the leaders of this experiment is
Professor Francis Housen we have an
interview with him that you can find
over here it's a question I've never had
the nature of space-time has puzzled
thinkers philosophers physicists and
astronomers for centuries going back to
the early Greeks who had the earliest
Notions of what space-time was some
people say space and time are emergent
phenomena that's not the subject today
instead today we're looking at the
properties of invariance how things
don't change and they maintain symmetric
properties despite how you look at them
and where you look at them from back in
the late 1800s Michelson and Morley The
two scientists at Case Western Reserve
University my proud alma mater
did interferometric measurements using a
so-called Michelson interferometer to
see if the speed of light depended on
how the Earth was removing with respect
to the ether wind
more than a hundred years later
astronomers are using interference
patterns as well to look for the
signatures not of ordinary Motion in
ordinary space time under ordinary
gravitational forces but to look for
Quantum gravitational forces and they're
not using a physical interferometer like
Michaelson and Morley they're using
interference patterns of neutrinos
themselves
using ice cube an experiment of a cubic
kilometer of ice buried deep under the
ice at the South Pole scientists have
peered into the structure of space-time
looking for new physics that could be
written into the properties of the ghost
particle known as the neutrino the Ice
Cube neutrino Observatory has been
operating for over a decade at the South
Pole it's made up of thousands of
sensors photo sensors that look for
flashes of light
these are buried 2 500 meters below the
Antarctic Ice about the length of 28
American football fields down there down
under deep below the ice they capture
energetic neutrino signatures that
originate in explosive events from the
Edge of Time and Space
that's what they had been doing until
this survey brought to our attention the
fact that they could actually probe the
nature of reality itself what is real
the Ice Cube collaboration a team of
more than 400 scientists announced the
quote search for new space-time
structure probing regions of the
universe that were previously
inaccessible by human Technologies what
makes ice cube so unique aside from the
fact that it's the largest neutrino
Observatory on Earth is that it's
particularly sensitive to neutrinos
coming from extreme distances
beyond our galaxy
and these neutrinos come and deliver a
wallop they pack a very high punch
associated with their extreme High
Energies let's take a step back we've
we've discussed neutrinos many times in
this channel what are they
well they're ghost particles for a
reason they don't interact other than by
either gravitational forces which is
related to their Mass like anything that
has mass and neutrinos are known to have
a mass but we don't know exactly how
much mass they have and that's part of
the goal of experiments like the Simon's
Observatory that I am running with my
colleagues from around the world and
Chile
neutrinos come in three different
flavors the electron flavor muon flavor
and Tau flavor they're so lightweight
that till now astronomers have never
detected their masses we have lower
limits on their Mass we have upper
limits on their Mass but we haven't
detected the mass themselves because
they only interact via gravity and the
weak nuclear force they don't interact
with light so they're a form of dark
matter they're able to effortlessly pass
through stars and planets and people
without slowing down or changing
direction even though they're so
abundant in the universe that over a
hundred trillion of them are passing
through you right now so neutrinos are
very very devil they're very difficult
to detect with conventional
instrumentation in fact they're the only
form of dark matter that scientists have
ever detected see a video about that
here most of the neutrinos penetrating
you right now are blasted out by the Sun
but there's another class of high-energy
astrophysical neutrinos that come from
cosmic accelerators located many
billions of light years from Earth these
accelerators could be objects called
blazars which are active Galactic nuclei
that blast out Jets of light particles
and energy but the exact source of
astrophysical neutrinos is at present
unknown
as these wispy Poltergeist particles
propagate from these distant
astrophysical sources they can oscillate
or change from one flavor state to
another due to Quantum interference
effects now a particularly important
property of these neutrinos is that
they're very very sensitive to the
properties of the vacuum the background
space time in which they're propagating
any perturbations in the energy density
of the vacuum can be used to hunt for
the imprint of space-time substructure
on the neutrino oscillations themselves
to conduct their search
Ice Cube researchers used seven and a
half years of their high energy starting
events which they call h-e-s-e events
these include some of the highest
astrophysical energy neutrinos ever
observed what the Ice Cube team did is
measure the relative abundance of the
different flavors of neutrinos their
so-called neutrino flavor composition at
their Earthbound detector because the
two properties mentioned earlier that
neutrinos can travel the longest
distances in the universe the largest
the longest distance is traversed by any
massive particle of course light can
Traverse the whole universe and because
they don't get really deflected because
they only interact weekly and Via
gravity their ideal sources to study the
universe at its highest energies that's
a bingo this actually probes inverse to
the energy in terms of Link skills so
the higher the energy the smaller length
scales one can probe so you're probing
things at Great distances allowing tiny
effects to accrue to macroscopic values
similar to what we discussed when we
described Cosmic birefringence in this
video up here now here's the key Insight
scientists had long suspected that
changes in the flavor of astrophysical
neutrinos could open a window into
regions of space-time that might defy
what's known as Lorenz symmetry now
lorenzymmetry is the important
underlying bedrock of Einstein's special
theory of relativity itself the Bedrock
of all of modern physics in that we
believe that quantum mechanics obeys
special relativity and we believe that
gravity which follows general relativity
also subsumes within its special
relativity so having a window into
Lorent symmetry could look for cracks in
the foundations of all of modern physics
just a quick pause to ask you for a
small favor while my thumb is occupied
with old Albert on it yours is
presumably freed up to leave a thumbs up
on this video really helps me a lot with
a good old-fashioned YouTube algorithm
thanks a lot now back to the video
Lorenz symmetry I sometimes summarize as
the fact that the universe doesn't care
about you
doesn't care where you are who you are
what you are how fast you're moving
which way you're tilted or rotating
whatsoever as long as two observers are
traveling in what are called inertial
frames relatively speaking moving a
constant velocity with respect to each
other then they should observe the same
types of properties the Universe At
Large scales in other words is basically
isotropic and homogeneous means it looks
the same isotropy and homogeneity means
as effectively has the same properties
if you translate your position to a
different region of space that's true on
the largest scales although there have
been criticisms of the so-called
cosmological principle that states that
this is true throughout the entire
universe more on that in another video
even though the universe appears highly
anisotropic when we look at the cosmic
retro background it's actually very very
tiny departures of order one part and 10
to the fourth or 10 to the fifth
relative to the background temperature
of the CMB is what we observe in terms
of its anisotropy now the planetary
perspective we enjoy on Earth we see
effectively large-scale departures for
misotropy and it's a good thing we
wouldn't be here if that wasn't true
broaden your horizons beyond your local
parochial distance skill and look at a
cosmic distance scales the cosmological
principle holds remarkably true on those
large scales but if something was wrong
in laurent's symmetry if there was
so-called lorentz invariance violation
that means non-respecting of the
symmetry of boosts and rotations that I
talked about earlier
another please you might see the effects
on gravity in the standard model of
particle physics because they're so high
energy
and because they come from so far away
they're undeflected unmolested as they
travel through the universe these
neutrinos are ideal candidates to probe
the structure of quantum gravity you
need something that's massive unlike the
photon to do this type of astroparticle
test for lorentz invariance asymmetries
we along with my late great colleague Dr
Andrew Friedman
studied lorentz and variance violation
using the polarization properties of
distant active Galactic nuclei as well
neutrinos that pass to Regions that have
departures from local orense and variant
symmetry could potentially switch
flavors in surprising new ways that
would leave a record of the space-time
anomalies that they've traversed along
their paths to the Earth
these signatures could be imprinted on
the neutrino flavor oscillations and
scientists would read them out on Earth
but there are some challenges neutrinos
switch flavors even without this
space-time effect and that has been
known since the experiments that we've
talked about the so-called solar
neutrino problem that led to an
understanding of neutrino oscillation
this oscillation can interfere
constructively or destructively and now
is the focus of the research conducted
by the Ice Cube team tape katori who's
an assistant professor at the King's
College of London and one of the lead
authors on the analysis said that this
comparison what they did is make a
simulation of what they would see in the
standard model and then they extended it
to incorporate potential departures from
Lorenz invarings using a framework
that's called SME standard model
extensions and that we've used before
and many many other colleagues have
looked for before and as I discussed we
will show more about that in a future
video in the cosmic polarization of
light frame of reference the simulation
that the Ice Cube team generated showed
that the flavor model that was needed to
include the effects of quantum gravity
could result in interference of these
flavors in the oscillation that they
experience the flavor ratio is one of
the most powerful probes known to look
for so-called new physics or departures
from the standard model or extensions to
the standard model meaning that this
could be used in the most powerful way
to look for departures from Lorenzen
variants which again underpins all of
special relativity which underpins
itself all of modern physics and this is
exactly what you want when you're
looking for new things you need a solid
prediction of what to look for which
comes from your theoretical friends you
need an accurate and precise
experimental observation which comes
from observers and precision of the
powerful Ice Cube neutrino telescope and
those two combined together give
scientists the ability to peer deep into
the recesses of space-time looking for
deviations produced by new
measured neutrino flavors were then
compared with those expected from the
oscillation and interference of
oscillation patterns during their Voyage
from the active Galactic nuclei the
Blazers to the Ice Cube detector now is
where we come to the sad day new month
of the story
the researchers obtained a null result
but
sometimes no news
is good news because the Ice Cube
scientists found no anomalies in the
neutrino flavor conversion that left the
notion of Lorenz symmetry intact for now
but a powerful result just like the
Michelson Morley result was a null
result it didn't depression it made us
rethink our underlying Paradigm
eventually leading Einstein and others
to conclude that the speed of light was
constant in the case of Michelson Morley
now the leaders of the Ice Cube
experiment are perhaps a little bit more
moderate in terms of the impact of their
null result but it's not necessarily
disappointing other than we like to
detect things in physics rather than
constrain things but that's a personal
bias that human beings have the truth is
the truth and Reporting it in the most
accurate reproducible way is what is the
Hallmark of good science
despite not finding new physics
it's still an important find ice cube
was able to unambiguously reach the
parameter space of quantum gravity
motivated physics according to the
researchers in the nature study the
results have blazard ablazed a new Trail
into the theoretical domain of looking
for quantum gravity with neutrinos it's
incredible when you think about it the
neutrino has only been around for about
90 years and now physicists can use it
to probe gravity which itself has only
had a classical General relativistic
description for 105 years or so Ice Cube
has the highest sensitivity ever and
they were also the first experiment to
reach this new region where phase space
could reveal laurent's violating
properties and the good news is that
these scientists are now looking deeper
into the effects and how they would be
manifest and the different parameters
that describe how space-time could be
defective
unprecedented glimpse into the shadowy
Realms of the neutrino ghostly
underworld that had remained Out Of
Reach until just now even as the initial
experiment comes to a Bittersweet end
there's a new beginning emerging
crystallized underneath the Antarctic
ice shelf the Ice Cube collaboration is
looking deeper at the data again using
what's called machine learning
techniques that I'll describe in future
videos and these could nail down
anomalies that were missed in the
initial study the team is also
dramatically expanding the size of the
Ice Cube detector so
today was a good day today was a good
day at least for astronomers trying to
obtain a deeper insight into the traces
of space-time anomalies that may lead us
to quantum gravity the future looks
bright for these astrophysical neutrino
oscillations and their ability to probe
quantum gravity the universal space-time
structure at the smallest regions
to learn more about ghostly neutrinos
check out this playlist that I made just
for you
[Music]